Hey, DT is watching on Twitch. What are you going to do? You
almost thought you got me. You almost thought you had me, but
not today. He's just showing fire for the first time. He's just
showing fire for the first time. He's like >> Yes. You're
really Are you trying to like make things hot? Like what the
How are you How are you doing I don't know what I'm looking at
here. Do you think Hutch is aware that he's nowhere near as intelligent
as his son? Do you think he knows that like >> Probably
not. No, he probably genuinely thinks he's smarter than his son.
You please just explain the situation. Okay, so there is a clipping
Discord that I'm a part of, okay? I will ask for links to stuff.
Uh I will suggest clips to people. I'll retweet other people's
clips. Right? Basically, they're trying to post like cut up logs
with absent any context as if this is like an evil doxing server.
Destiny wants this to go and flow into his greater narrative
that I'm running like a cabal that's been working against him,
that hates him, and wants to undermine everything he's ever So,
but he did this. He said, "Got to say I'm not terribly surprised
to have found this in the leaked snark Discord logs. Folks, this
is online politics. If you're invoking dead family members over
this stuff, you're years overdue for extensive therapy. Delete
your accounts and reevaluate."
So, they cut off whoever the [__] this was. Now,
if someone like that was doing something like that, I think that
there would probably be a level of value in at least putting
the screen name there. You want the people that own the server
to be able to go, "No, we saw that and we've banned them." But,
this isn't what I do. I've never been like this. Okay, hold on.
I got to go find Hutch's stream. I actually haven't grabbed it
here at all. Give me a second. Give me a second. Give me a second.
It's not going to scramble. This is the one. This is the one.
So, here's this. He's got a 5-hour 54-minute vod on YouTube.
8 hours?
Oh my god.
I think uh today a snarker was born, okay? Welcome to the snark
side, Hutch.
Welcome, my friend.
Doesn't it feel liberating to just admit that you didn't really
have political like goals? You were just a guy who did internet
drama. Doesn't that feel liberating? Isn't that a liberating
Yes, I am a snarker. YES, I DO LOVE SNARKING. Welcome to the
team, Hutch. Welcome to the team.
You don't get it. He doesn't participate in these spaces. I've
heard this. I've heard Hutch is not a drama streamer. He's a
political streamer and sometimes he looks at drama. Occasionally
looks at drama. Occasionally.
Like him trying to walk through the film on stuff and just not
understanding what like anything that's going on would be very
funny. Does he have some kind of an automated website? I'm assuming
that's what this is where you automate to like
monitor people's streams or is this just monitoring everyone's
streams? I don't even know what I'm looking at here. He's like
looking so desperately
to discern that it's actually shocking. Oh my god, a website
exists on the internet where you can search me? Oh my god. Dude,
he's like the guy from Gremlins.
What voice? What kind of voice is he doing there? What is that
voice? It's a voice. It's a voice. What What you
A website exists on the internet where you can search me? I'm
hamming it up now, okay? That's fair, Top Bronson, that he wouldn't
even moderate his chat going after Pisco. Of course, he's not
going to moderate his chat going after me. Of course not. That's
fine. That's a level of onlineness that I never that I never
reached, but I I genuinely
had no idea that this was a thing. Uh the trip was $5. Damn,
this moment is telling. It could be
It could just be that they have no legit human interaction because
they didn't vibe well with others, so the only I don't know.
Listen, I don't want to I I it's a pretty safe assumption that
the level of activity, the frequency of activity in this Discord
channel
I [laughter] love that character.
I [__] >> That is a little bit like the voice.
That That was a discerning chatter who donated that. That is
very similar to the voice, actually. Love that movie. >> good
stuff. Matt Reeves is such a legend. He could have Oh god, he's
going to go way off He's going to go way off on a tangent here.
thinking about that
It's gone. What's up?
Yeah, it's uh Watching some Hutch.
Yeah, I was just checking out Hutch. Apparently watched me for
like 8 hours today, 7 hours or something.
>> the involvement in the community that you feel as a
part of this like snarky
Maybe that's filling a hole that you have, I don't know. My god.
Some kind of an automated website? I'm assuming that's what this
is? Where you automate the like
monitor people's streams? Or is this just monitoring everyone's
streams? I don't even know what I'm looking at here. Search within
YouTube subtitles, captions, and and transcripts. It's just like
K Mon bro. This is
He's just flying off for the first time. He's just flying off
for the first time. He's like Yes. You're really You're trying
to You're really trying to like make things hot? Like what the
How you How you doing How you doing looking at here? It's like
bright and hot at the same time? How is How? >> Search
It's just a broad search. It searches like the whole internet.
It's just It doesn't even like
It basically like is You're not downloading anything to your
computer. And for Hutch's channel, and as far as Ogre Boy is
concerned, Hutch's channel has just been indexed for a long time.
This is the funny thing. It's like once all this is explained,
you understand that Hutch's whole thing about being surveilled
24/7 entirely falls apart the moment he doesn't understand what
Film Mod is. It's in the
You guys are actively watching my content live obsessively. This
is not I just want to point out that for today I couldn't get
a single person to give me timestamps for this. I have to go
and find myself. Okay, okay. Can I actually explain to me if
if this is so evil, how the does he think all the Hasan clips
get generated that he covers? How the does he think the anti-Hasan
machine runs? What does he think is happening? Does he think
it's Hasan's fans going around posting those clips? Do you think
people just genuinely enjoy watching Hasan's content? They catch
these moments and they go and make a bunch. No, there are legions
upon legions of obsessed
liberal right-wing Discord
that sit around staring at Hasan all day and hate this guy cuz
he limits and that's what that's all they do all day and they
cry about it. They get deranged about it and then they go and
post about it. They post about who is a terrorist. They post
about who kids. Who is listening to this? >> to know a
funny thing? Do you want to know a funny thing? Is actually the
first Film Mod equivalent that I became aware of was this one
right here.
This was for Destiny. Do you want to know who they quickly expanded
to as a secondary source for YouTube
Hasan [__] So, like we're literally just following
in footsteps here, okay? We're trying to catch up to people who've
already built this exact into No, that's that's like operated
with for a long period of time. That that's the the DGG have
like a million things like this. They have like a bunch of different
web projects and all this that they've set up over the years
that have been tracking different people and all this [__]
They've always done that. It's like that this is these are your
people, bro. It's your guys. Hutch thinks like Willy Mac gets
me to look like he's above 60 IQ with no effort. No, bro. It
took a lot of effort from a lot of people, okay? It took a Herculean
It was It was a Herculean >> a village. Takes a village,
as they say.
Not just about transcripts. He knows this. I don't know why he's
doing this.
That was specifically Tony that was doing that, who was apparently
working on a video for like months that I don't know if it ever
came out, but
But then they would have these like watch parties for Livin'
Learn, and you know, like they weren't watch Yeah, we're fans
of Livin' Learn.
We're all We're all fans of Livin' Learn. What? What's wrong
with that? watching my stuff as religiously as they were watching
other creators, but there would be uh most days, I want to say,
there would be like days that I was live, you know, you would
see like is anybody watching Hutch live right now? He's being
so regarded on this thing. Did it Like stuff like that. And then,
you know, like and then there were Yeah, and
they destroyed like every Discord in this whole space. Like Like
every Discord in this whole space would have people doing this.
People would be I think I did this in my Discord today. I asked
if people were watching I might have asked if they were watching
Hutch live cuz I heard he was watching me.
Like every Everybody says this in every Discord ever. Hey, what
are you guys doing? Anyone watching this? They're content creator
Discords. They're content-centric Discords. Of course, people
are going to ask these questions.
Or more examples of like targeted stuff where they're like boosting
tweets that are or brigading posts and stuff like that. There
was like plenty of plenty of that as well. On the anti-Starker
side,
this fantastic
[__] has
come into this video. He's trying to tell you that these people
are stalking me. They're finding videos from like 10 years ago.
Oh my god. And he is unaware that you could just search the
He can't even disagree with that. He literally just said you
were unaware of that. Is a totally unreliable person. He is totally
out of his depth trying to talk about this. And he's basically
lying to slander other people to create a permission structure
to docs them. So, thank you, Hutch. He doesn't understand what
he's participating in at all.
No, he's just a bot. Um people have been posting like what Destiny
said is my location in in the chat repeatedly. And he gets to
do this face.
He gets to do this face after I suggest
Stupid Uh Oh, we're on Twitch. We're on Twitch. We're on Twitch.
Hey, Twitch. Hey, Twitch. Hey, DGG is watching on Twitch waiting
to do You almost thought you got me. You almost thought you had
me, but not today. Not today, okay? What? What? He just took
a gigantic
leap there. What
That's very funny.
Hutch just I don't know if he Does he think to tell his like
his mods? I don't know. Maybe he just doesn't think of it. I
actually watch my chat. So, for me, like I I know if I see somebody
spamming like info like that in my chat, I just I get rid of
them really quick. I've always got an eye on it. I don't know
what Hutch's excuse is here, but What did he just say? I just
[__] For coming into this whole situation Denims,
actually, uh I thought had some issues with moderating a chat
that Hutch was very upset about.
Oh, yeah.
Well, you know, that's that's Denims. That is Denims, okay? >> Yeah,
that's them, and this is us. She's like anti-Semitic, I heard.
So, realistically, she needs to be a better person. So, Hutch
is trying to create the standard for being totally insane, totally
unhinged, totally crazy.
And who built this custom themselves before anybody else on the
internet had an open channel that they could just add whatever
they wanted to? Who did that? UH OH, IT WAS DGG. WAIT, REALLY?
YES, I'm Listen, I say first is the first one I was aware of,
and there was not a broad generic search before that, okay? Uh
Rintharp with $5, damn you didn't know about a website. This
clearly invalidates everything, case closed. For the record,
I think some parts of DGG
can be
way too online and obsessive
in ways that I don't think is healthy.
But will also monetize and take advantage of as much as humanly
possible, including watching 7 hours of your vod today. Which
by the way, I just make it clear, I've no problem with. I love
that hard that Hutch is coming over to the snark side, okay?
That he's seen the the snark side of things. I love that for
him. Is that if he doesn't think this is like uniquely bad, then
what what is even the point of this coverage? Why is he spending
6 hours a day talking about this? Well, it's obviously more harmful
than Trump or anything else that's going on in American politics
right now, idiot.
Hey, live your life, do what makes you happy, but
I don't know if he's looking for some kind of a contradiction.
I think this kind of behavior
obsessive behavior is just generally, you know, like
probably not fulfilling to people on a spiritual level. I'm not
joking, this is something I This is how you he gives away that
he can't possibly win, right? Cuz he's giving away that it's
not fulfilling to him on a spiritual level. And he assumes that
that is what's is true for everybody else, right? That's like,
"Oh, buddy, you got no idea.
You're somewhere you don't want to be, and I'm in like my happy
place. I'm in I'm in like the zone. I'm having a great time every
day. I wake up, I have a great I'm very confident on. And it
isolates the clips, too.
Uh you know what's funny is I was just thinking last night, like,
you know what? I wonder how he's doing. This is It's so funny
that this is the example that he brings up. Is me calling attention
to the fact that we've done like an ogre boy ban ban in the in
the chat. I wonder what he's up to.
And so, I'm just saying for everybody here, okay?
What is the website? It's filmot. Film ot. filmot.com.
Subscribe to the Patreon like I have. I subscribed to the Patreon
cuz I use it a decent amount, right? If I want to go find stuff
for anything. And if you search on filmot it pulls up a captcha
unless you sign up for the Patreon, so. Uh yeah, it searches
the transcripts and uses timestamps to clip from the vod, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Which is very funny. I The funny thing is is I built this myself
like three summers ago. YouTube transcript search It piped it
into a like an elastic search index, essentially. It was It was
It wasn't elastic search. It was a Lucene compliant search index.
Basically, just something you use to search text. Don't worry
about it if you don't know. And it would timestamp all the logs.
And so you would search through and I've just listen, I've never
been this like I think I'm pretty engaged
in online discourse. I think I'm pretty engaged specifically
like in online political discourse. I've just never been this
engaged. I'm not I'm not necessarily judging. It's like, "Okay,
if that's your passion, but I've never been that
I I've never been I've never felt a motivation to run that kind
of like automated system of like focusing on specific creators
in this kind of way. So, he's saying he's saying he's not that
engaged, right? It's like
You clearly care about it, right? You are You He's saying he's
engaged. He's saying he cares about it. He's saying he's not
that engaged. I understand not wanting to spend all of your time
doing this. That's kind of the point of automating it is that
you can do more with less time. That's that's the point of having
archivers, having clippers, having people praying your dockets,
having automated systems for doing that is is to be able to do
more with less time, have more of an impact, be more effective
with less time. So, why would you not do that? If you're even
remotely engaged, why would you not do that?
I'm just trying to think in my head
you think Hutch just doesn't understand how like journalism works
or No.
No, he did not just Just be normal.
Just be normal. Who's got the s- It's just normal. It's so normal
to just not care about your job. >> it's like so cuz it's
like all the sh- he does, all the songs he covers requires a
bunch of people not being normal. He's not normal when he covers
Hasan. It just To to act like Oh, you have to stop doing this
cuz this this isn't normal. It's like you just You just say you
don't like hearing it. Just say you don't want us to exist online.
Just say you don't want us to be effective. Just say that cuz
that's what you mean. That's what you mean. You're mad there's
a bunch of people who hate you and they're motivated to point
out the ways in which you're lying to people or you're really
stupid or you're self-interested
and you don't like that. You don't like they do that because
you don't want what happened to Hasan to happen to you. It's
going to, buddy. It's going to. Do you think Hutch is aware that
he's nowhere near as intelligent as Hasan? Do you think he knows
that like >> Holy no. No, he probably genuinely thinks
he's smarter than Hasan. Yeah, that's unfortunate.
And by the way, I don't think either of us think Hasan's like
a world beater in terms of IQ. I just It's just Hutch. It's just
Hutch. Who's got the um the Bastiat Tangia? Just be normal. Don't
do this obsessive >> that mean Hutch will be that relevant.
That's It's not quite what I meant by you know the Hasan you
know his gravity. I just mean he's going to get the same sort
of criticism and that's how it
And also obviously he will not have a
you know
Hutch is never going to be on a on a million thumbnails, you
know, being like He's He's done now. He's 1,000% good. No one's
ever going to give that much of a [__] about Hutch.
No third worlders are ever going to be able to make a like incredible
living off of Hutch. It's never going to happen, man. Facts.
And then be like, uh have you ever heard of journalism?
He did There's no way he just said that. I mean, he was really
like racking his
How do I react to that? Oh, let's frame it as journalism.
It's no way he just said that. Or
or like video content creation works,
He's literally like, "Oh, this guy's like trying to verify claims
he made." And He's not trying to verify claims I made. He's constantly
searching for his name on the internet. That's like
Because well, actually it's claim you made. I don't know what
I meant there. It sounded like I meant Ogerboy, but it's a claim
Hutch made. Hutch said, "I have an Ogerboy policy. I haven't
mentioned Ogerboy since back here." And Ogerboy goes, "Oh, really?"
And then he pulls up Phil Mott and he searches Ogerboy. Like
he just wants to in real time verify the claim.
different. That's not the same thing as journalism. That's just
I That's a level of of self-indulgence that You see how he can't
let it play for very long? Like he he just paused it there. I
said journalism or video content creation, any of this stuff
where you like have to do research, verify your claims. Like
obviously somebody's going to make this process more efficient.
But he's basically saying, "Oh, you said you're a journalist.
Oh my god, you think you're like a journalist?" No. Nobody's
arguing that, Hutch. Most creators don't even do.
Well, established creators. And he's not using chat GPT.
What a sad, strange little man.
stuff that he's saying in a private Discord. And then but but
this level of sad, like this level of [__]
We're just we have completely fallen off the cliff.
Phil Mott. Phil Mott is totally pathetic, guys. If you try to
search for mentions of a word, of a concept, does Hutch not realize
how powerful This is what we call kind of a combination
No, no, no. Hold on. Maybe he did it. He would have to apologize
to Ogerboy before anything else here, right? He's implying Ogre
Boy using this tool, having this tool is totally pathetic. Ogre
Boy is a total loser for this. And now he's going to try to get
out of apologizing for that and saying he was wrong. No, you
you made a bunch of reads about Ogre Boy not knowing what this
was. You should apologize for that,
of a straw man and a motte and bailey.
Little bit of both in there. Okay. That's specifically what I'm
calling pathetic. Is like Filmon or do you think it's like part
of like a larger context? Do you think this is just one one element
of Ogre Boy's very apparent obsession with me?
what this tool is for making his arguments when he's talking
about other content creators? Does he not realize where all of
this [__] that people found on Hasan? He's not doing
that though. He's not like active in debates. He's just looking
he's just he just logs into the internet every day, I guess,
and just pulls up Here's here's the thing. If you are a
Oh, how would I If you're like a creator, and I mean that like
a sort of spiritual sense. If you're like a creator, if you're
like a builder, if you If you're looking to be
somebody who iterates and and makes things better in the world,
you should see this tool and go, "Holy I didn't even know this
was possible." Like a a person that I would want to interact
with or collab with would look at this tool and go, "Holy This
is possible? Well, that's awesome. Oh, I need that. Oh, how do
you How do you use this?" Right? They wouldn't go, "Oh, you're
so creepy and weird for wanting to know about this." Like this
inherent disgust at new knowledge is very concerning for
I think your reaction to this should just objectively be, "Oh
my god, you can search all of YouTube? What? Like I can search
for Hutch specifically? I can search for like Hasan across all
of YouTube? What? What?" Filmon searches for Ogre Boy looking
for like any crumb of online attention.
comes from? Do you not realize that when people want to make
a point about Hasan with regards to Marxism or communism?
I'm almost positive when Ogre Boy is looking this up, by the
way, it's to verify claim that Hutch made about how he stopped
talking about Ogre Boy months ago. And Ogre Boy looks it up and
goes, "Oh, look at the mentions of OgreBoy here." Or what's the
other one?
Right? They use this website. All of your people who get you
links would use a website just like this.
All of my people who give me links Listen, sometimes you guys
give me some stuff to point out to, but I I personally pick
probably like 99%
of the stuff that I I don't maybe he operates this way where
he's got people like feeding him clips. I don't do that.
I mean, I do, but that's cuz I want to have like all the best
I Yeah, I do. But why is Hutch pretending he doesn't? Is Hutch
saying that his obsession with Hasan was just all him? Nobody
sent him links for that? I just don't think that's true. Or at
least I hoped it wasn't true. But hey, maybe. Maybe maybe. I'm
a normal person. I don't play this game that you play.
I I assume this is projection. I assume people feed you clips
and these kinds of things. Okay, yes he does. He does play this
game. What does he mean? Is the Hasan thing here? We're all playing
the same game, bro. We're all playing the same game. How dare
It really does come down to just How dare you be effective? How
dare you be better at this than me? How dare you? You're like
weird cuz you're you're You're like making good points and you're
like >> few of you, but but you seem so loud. It's so annoying.
It's so annoying.
Why does it hit so hard even though there's so few of you? That's
that [__] annoys me so much.
Is that okay? fantastic tool. If you ever wanted to debate with
somebody who disagrees with you, like a content creator, you
could go and find their positions that they've held and see if
they're like wobbly on this, see where they're wobbly on this,
see how they argue it. It would be fantastic for you. It's like
an Honestly, moving forward, I might use it. Wasn't aware of
this. It would have been helpful in a few debates.
I thought you wanted to disengage. I thought you just wanted
to disengage.
It turns out this is not loser behavior. It turns out Oh my god.
>> this is pretty useful. Turns out actually it's kind
of awesome. This is good for you. >> He's been just as
much mentioning me as
I should be Negative. >> The last thing on his mind. What
is that based on, Hutch? Hutch, what is that based on? I've been
I could ask Claude. Hang on, let me ask Claude. Estimate
how much time in raw
total hours
that Ogre Boy spent. He's going to ask Oh, did he upload all
the logs into Claude or something? Watching my streams
or talking about
me in this channel. Dude, there's no way There's no way that's
a context clue. >> What is he Does he have it
Yeah, there's no way if he's asking like AI or giving it no context
clues whatsoever, that's That would be shocking. >> How
many total hours? It's thinking. It's thinking.
Har Star says 69 hours. You think Claude can do that? LOL. >> Dude,
I >> We got 80 hours, 67, 300, 1,000. That is ambitious.
I don't know if I would have gotten that high, but maybe honestly
maybe. I'll let it hit. I've got pause. >> The memer seems
to have got it right. Har Star, you nailed it, buddy. This says
69 hours. He wasn't even the most Actually wait, hold on. Is
this 74 hours? Hang on, we got to refine this a little bit. Hang
on. Ap- Apparently there were there were other users that like
doubled his hours.
Okay, this is something set up with the context for the logs.
I got it. Oh man, this is so powerful.
There's no way Dude, imagine how obsessed you'd have to be to
set up like a Chat GPT context that you could share around or
for Hutch to set it up with Where he puts all of these logs into
it. Or somebody else sets it up and he's given like access to
it.
Why does he take the fruits of labor of so many obsessed people
and use them directly and then mock others who do the same?